let's go to your voicemails two one nine
two david p here's an interesting
suggestion from a caller but i just
don't know that i actually agree with
the premise let's take a listen to it
together and see if we can figure it out
hey David I had a pretty depressing
political prospect for you what if I'm
the sole reason for the midterms not
being the big success
everyone was hoping there would be was
just caravan news in the MPC meme any
thoughts yeah so number one I don't know
that the election was such a bad result
for Democrats I mean I get that we all
kind of wanted more but it it really
wasn't a bad result for Democrats that's
number one number two I don't think the
NPC meme had anything to do with the
election results have you seen anything
Pat to suggest that that stupid NPC meme
influenced the way the midterms went the
vast majority of people have no idea
what the NPC meme is I would say that
ninety percent of people don't know what
a non playable character is and a few
weeks ago I was part of that 90 percent
you know what I actually was told it's
not necessarily non playable character
it's non oh and now I'm even forgetting
I mean it's basically the same thing but
it's not non playable non non player
character I guess to the gamers there's
like a really big difference between the
two but we know what you're talking
about a pre-programmed character that
reacts in non-thinking ways or we give
me a break this is the list course
around politics now this actually counts
as discourse in some parts of the
internet and that's what you are of
course the total NPC as I've seen from
all the YouTube comments yeah I know if
you if you now go to our YouTube channel
and search for NPC like we can search
all of our comments for certain keywords
the frequency with which NPC is being
used in comments is uh is is disturbing
to say the least we have a great bonus
show for you today I am going to argue
that the White House Correspondents
Association is doing something really
stupid this year
we'll talk about a pro-life bill that
allows for the possibility of the death
penalty for abortion providers and
pregnant people and a source says that
the Cleveland Browns want to interview
condi rice for the head coaching job all
of those stories and many more on
today's bonus show look forward to
speaking to you then